what does what what are
the skills needed to run a business like
what what does it involve uh so here's
here's what I like to think of um Monday
morning meeting getting the whole team
together everyone's got a job to do
everyone declares their three things to
six things that they're going to do for
the week um as in the most important
things not micromanaging but what are
the three to six big things you're going
to do for the week um and then um on
Friday we talk about what did we get
done what didn't we get done um we keep
a dashboard so we have a dashboard of
like did we make sales did we were there
any customer complaints do we need to
solve any problems um so those kind of
things
happen um and then essentially a general
manager is like doing all the little
problem solving along the way so for
example loading up payments and then the
payments go out and um collections or
there's a customer who didn't pay and
they needed an email saying you need to
pay um so that's a bit of financial
control um later on you might have a
financial controller who just does that
general manager can do that um
scheduling hiring uh if we need to hire
someone new if someone wants to go on a
holiday who's going to cover for them
like all that
stuff yeah that's basically what Angus
does yeah yeah and you're and and most
importantly they know that their job is
to keep you out on the front line yeah
you have to be out there with when I'm
when I'm away at a conference the whole
team is happy oh yeah no big time
totally because if I don't you didn't do
a lot of how long did did you how long
were you a doctor like 2 years dear it's
a bit different cuz there's not an owner
but like was there ever a big boss is
there a big like Hospital general
manager or hospital it's like the
hospital CEO but like the doctors don't
really interact with the management
structure of the organization yeah
they're the technical technicians is
there anyone like who's like represents
like the big scary regional manager or
someone
who point is is that normally that's not
your best day at work when that person
person's buzzing around um I I had an
experience for me personally where like
I worked at McDonald's as a teenager and
when the big boss was in town and when
the big boss was in the store we all
froze and we didn't work very well um
and I also worked around uh some people
who were very well known um and when
they were around everyone froze no one
worked really well
so less is more when you hit a certain
point you're far better off just being
out there being this you know being the
key person of influence doing deal
raising profile doing Partnerships
finding opportunities all the all of
that stuff um being in contact and
connection with your customers in your
Marketplace um pitching publishing
product creation writing a book um all
of that doing a podcast that is like
your high value Superstar stuff and then
the team you just need to check in with
them like me personally I kind of check
in with my teams now every like 90 days
I keep an eye on the dashboard like
genuinely there was a business I just
solded for quite a lot of money like
Millions um I owned it for about four or
five years and um I probably spoke to
the managing director six times in that
whole time oh
hell yeah like and and never
visited like didn't go on site I own I
own several businesses that I've never
been to like genuinely I've never been
there um as in they have an office I've
never
been how the hell does that
work you I bought the business and we
met we met at a we met down the road
here at this local place down the road
and we did a deal and I let them get on
with
it why would you buy that business uh
because I can grow it and how and you
grow it by virtue of by being a key
person of influence because you're the
Eiffel Tower so you can be the combine
harvest throwing opportun way throw
opportunities their way but I don't need
to know provided I know the person who
running that business can handle the
opportunities and can run the business I
don't need to know what happens beyond
that point right I can see it on the I
can see it on the dashboards I can see
the p&l in the balance sheet um I can
see the weekly meetings are happening we
can do quarterly I can attend a
quarterly alignment session if I want to
um but so long as I have trust in my
team I don't need to be there very often
um I just need to be out and about
trying to trying to drum up opportunity
cuz this idea of like you know you you
own multiple
businesses feels like a stressful place
to be it's really not okay it's actually
really not um in fact I think it's
easier to own multiple businesses than
uh having um having just one cuz if
you've got one you obsess over it and if
you've got multiple businesses you only
deal with the stuff that needs to be
deal yeah I obsess over my one business
yeah so if if you actually have multiple
businesses yeah then the team you you
only have when you have multiple
businesses you only have one opportunity
which is to hire great people and let
them get on with it yeah cuz if you're
if you're working on several different
businesses at once the other thing too
is don't forget a bigger business is
multiple businesses like so when you
think about when you think about Google
it sounds like one thing from the
outside but it's like loads of things
Amazon is like loads of things I mean
there's like there's hundreds of
businesses in Amazon there's the Film
Production business like doing Amazon
Prime there's like the AWS business uh
there's different regions and
territories um
in team there's external engagement team
there's the B2B thing there's the fresh
delivery grocery services so they're all
product teams so this is multiple
multiple businesses that are within a
business a bu bigger business so when I
when I own multiple businesses it's just
essentially it's just a group group of
companies and yeah like each team is its
own team it's almost like if you if you
had multiple properties and the rent is
coming in you're just keeping an eye on
on the numbers making sure nothing
seriously is going wrong pretty much and
then you don't need to worry about it
too much yeah and if you only have one
business you'll solve every Problem by
throwing your own time at it Y and
you'll be ending up like doing things
that are not your main thing that you do
and if you have multiple businesses
you're like okay I mean the cool thing
is when you get multiple businesses is
you can actually say it would be easier
for me to buy another business than fix
this one
so guys guys sort it out like sort out
sort out the issue because uh and then
are you not worried that that if
something goes wrong that it will
reflect badly on your
brand um yeah to a degree I am worried
about that yep I do want to make sure
that the businesses succeed for that
reason y that's definitely a
consideration so I would you know that
and that's probably my primary worry
like reputation management if if a
business didn't succeed I want to make
sure that they do succeed for that
reason yeah H sounds pretty fun it is
fun well it's it moments if if multiple
things go wrong at at the same time you
can have a stressful couple of weeks
yeah I feel like this is not where I I
want to be right now but I can
imagine at some point at some point I'll
be like you know what I want to be more
of a coach to businesses and like just
own multiple businesses when you have
multiple businesses you are a coach to
your own business that that is very much
what you do you're the brand and you're
the coach um here's what very much could
happen for you you've got such a big
brand you could have multiple businesses
that you are an equity stakeholder in
and you play the key person of influence
role so like literally look at this
table you could contact this drinks
company and say hey I'll be the key
person of influence with this in
exchange for some equity and shares in
the business hey we'll um help promote
these in exchange for some Equity shares
in the business so you could have a
portfolio of businesses that you become
a shareholder in um and that you
evangelize those businesses you open up
opportunities while you're roaming
around having Adventures you're saying
Hey I just met some someone in Dubai
who's looking for a cucha drinks company
um to uh to to launch in the region um
Let me let me connect you both right so
you could actually very easily because
you've got such a great brand going you
could actually have multiple businesses
like next
month and if anyone would like that
please contact me as Ali's agent hey
friends thank you so much for watching
if you enjoyed this clip then click here
for the full unedited episode and if you
like that then do please consider
subscribing to the channel it means a
thank you so much and have a great day
bye-bye